- Hi, everyone, welcome to
the Khan Academy homeroom.
For those of y'all who are
wondering what this is,
this is just a forum for all of us
to stay together especially.
I was started when schools closed
and obviously it's summer right now.
So schools are continuing to be closed
and we could talk about what
might happen in back to school,
but then talk about anything,
obviously education topics,
but anything that's on your mind
and I'm really excited about our guests
that we have today.
We have a very exciting
announcement from Khan Academy.
Before I get into that,
I will give my standard
announcement remind everyone
that we are not for
profit that we only exist
because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
Special shout out to several
groups that have stepped up
right when they saw that
we were already running
at a deficit before COVID.
And that deficit grew because
we had increased traffic
we were trying to accelerate programs.
So Special thanks to Bank
of America, GOOGLE.org
fastly, NOVARTIS and AT&T and
the many other foundations
and corporations that have
supported Khan Academy,
pre COVID, and especially
during COVID crisis,
but we continue to run into deficit.
So any support donation
at any level is very,
very much appreciated if you're
in the position to do so.
So with that, I'm very excited
to introduce my colleague,
Meaghan Pattani, who works with partners
with teachers educators
around the country.
And Meaghan, we have a
very exciting announcement.
What is it?
- We do, Sal, we have an
exciting announcement.
We have just launched our
first course for teachers
in the United States and
called Khan For Educators,
to help teachers understand all the things
that are available on Khan Academy.
For teachers, I think
sometimes there's, you know,
an understanding that Khan
Academy has all these great
things for students.
But we also have a lot of really
great things for teachers.
And so we wanted to bring
that to the forefront.
And so we've created Khan For Educators,,
and it is free just like
the rest of Khan Academy
and available for educators everywhere.
- And, you know, we've always
had many tools for teachers,
teacher dashboards and reports
and ways to make assignments.
So this is a course to help teachers
understand all of these
different dimensions
that they can leverage in their schools
or with your students.
- You got it Sal, it's to teach teachers
what it's like to be a
student on Khan Academy.
The course is set up
the same way our courses
are for students so teachers
can learn what it feels
like to really be a
student on Khan Academy,
and then learn about you know,
a little more about Khan Academy's mission
about what mastery learning really is.
About all the amazing tools
and content that's available
for teachers to use with their students.
And then some best practices
that we've gathered
from teachers all over the country
who've been willing to share
their expertise and innovative
ways of using Khan
Academy in the classroom,
and to share those out more broadly.
- And to your point, this course,
it has what we call our
mastering mechanics.
Tell us more about that.
So there's a way for teachers to actually
not just kind of watch
videos and look at articles,
but they can get practice and feedback
on whether they grok
things or digested them.
- Yes, the same way we
encourage students to practice
and demonstrate what they've learned.
We're encouraging teachers to do the same.
And so this course is, you know,
founded in our mastery system,
and so along with videos and articles,
there are exercises and
unit tests for teachers
to demonstrate their understanding,
and if teachers earn
mastery on this course,
we will provide a
certificate of recognition.
And right now we're running a campaign
as well for any teacher who, you know,
masters the course and complete cert
and it does recognize
that they're significant,
they're entered into a
chance to win actually a zoom
one on one with you Sal.
- For whatever that's worth,
and we can see some of the screenshots,
these are screenshots both
of our teacher resources
and also we saw a little earlier
and we see Meaghan is definitely
one of the notable people
in the course itself on how
to be able to go through
these teacher readiness.
And for those who wanna use
it, it looks like they can go
to khan.co slash and all in caps K4EUS
it's down there at the bottom left.
Okay, you could see it repeated
but I'll say it actually
K4EUS comm for educators
US is what that stands for.
And already, we're getting some
nice comments and questions
from YouTube.
Suzanna Garcia Domingo
who was one of our regular
she's almost a kind of
part of our team now.
She's always had interesting
questions and comments
which she wrote, helps teachers
to understand and organize.
Great to have it all in one place,
best resource money
can't buy, there you go.
We'd like to believe
that we are invaluable.
But it's glad to hear that.
So there's one question
and I know the answer
and I you know the answer too
but it's good to answer it
because it's well,
the question is from Facebook,
the DaVita Hayes had chat.
Will this eliminate
the ambassador program?
I hope not.
I enjoy interactions with
my colleagues in this role.
- Of course not, we are really
grateful for our ambassadors
and for those who might be unfamiliar
with what the Khan Academy
ambassador program is.
The Khan Academy ambassador
program invites teachers
who are using Khan Academy
really consistently
and in innovative ways in
their classrooms, to you know,
join with others who
are doing similar things
and to share best practice
and provide training
to their other teammates can connect
directly with the academy team
to share what they're doing
up so we can learn more
about how we can improve
the product, how we can
support other teachers,
and so absolutely not the
Khan Academy ambassadors
are a huge asset to our organization
and definitely a huge asset to me.
And I couldn't have built this course
without really great
input from a whole bunch
of ambassadors.
- Yeah, and we often say
I often say very clearly,
if I had to pick between
an amazing teacher,
and amazing technology for my own kids
or anyone else's kids,
I would pick an amazing
teacher every time.
Luckily, you don't have
to make that trade off.
Ideally, you can create amazing technology
and service have amazing teachers.
And that also applies when
we talk about how do we teach
teachers or how do we
help support teachers.
Human beings are always going
to be the gold standard.
So our ambassador program
and our ambassador teachers
are really the rock stars
out there who are able
to you know, they live it every day.
They know what it's like to be a teacher.
And they're super users of Khan Academy.
So nothing can compare to
our ambassadors in terms
of being able to support other teachers
and how they can better
empower the students.
So yeah, it was a good question.
You know, I was surprised.
And I was like, who's
even thinking about that?
I would never.
But just in case that that's out there,
no, this is, we know, the
ambassador program is something
not only are we excited about
we've been growing about,
and if we could expand
it, and support it better,
we would love to figure
out ways we can do that.
So let's see.
So there's a couple of fun questions here.
Let's see.
We haven't never gotten this question
before from YouTube explorer questioner,
Sal and Meaghan, what are some of your go
to brain fuel snacks, right
now I'm having watermelon
and broccoli sprouts?
Meaghan, I'll let you
go because my recommend
is going to be more
fringe so people need time
to...
- Brain fuel snacks.
Okay, so two different
things I'd say during
when I'm in the office.
It's string cheese and carrot sticks,
which sounds fairly healthy at home,
it's definitely smores flavor LUNA bars,
much more chocolate.
I think that pandemic
has made my eating habits
probably a little bit worse.
- You started strong with
the cheese and carrots,
it's very helpful.
I've nothing against the LUNA Corporation
but have you ever seen the
sugar and caloric content
not to make you paranoid
about those things.
But, you know, you're anyway,
but the answer the same question.
Yeah, I mean, there's
definitely that there's a go
to as my animal brain wants me to have,
which is essentially just
like me, like, you know,
shoveling sugar into my
mouth, but the ones that I try
I've actually this my latest indulgence,
and this shows that I have
weaknesses for for sugar.
And I you know, they're not
sponsors of Khan Academy
in any way, shape or form,
but I know from Costco I've been getting
these like keto ice cream bars.
Tastes, you know, most ketogenic,
low carb stuff does not taste good,
especially when they try to make desserts.
This stuff is awesome.
So anyway, that's been my new thing
is my wife just planted
it's actually right outside
the window like, you know where
you can't see some planters
with some leafy greens
and there's something fun
about just like going
and eating them straight
from the plant like a
like a goat or something.
It's just like yeah,
I'm getting nutrients.
So those are, I think
those are my big ones.
I'm sorry for judging your LUNA bar.
I used to eat a lot of them until I
and I'm sure I'm gonna get
letters from LUNA you know.
The thing is, people
use the word energy bars
because you know, and like trail mix
and stuff like that because
when you're going hiking,
you do need a lot of calories
and you're burning it
and all that but then
that somehow got completed
I think intentionally
by the marketing machine that energy bar
is equal to healthy but obviously
if you're sitting around you know,
watching cartoons, which I do a lot of.
- It's not quite the same in fact. Yeah.
- Exactly.
Alright, so this may be
even slightly more serious
although what we put in our bodies
is a very important question.
YouTube Cortana Yenegala asks,
hello, what should we do to
prepare for an online test
and reduced test nervousness?
Meaghan love your point of view.
I'm happy to give mine as well.
- Well, what I used to tell my students
what I think is helpful is preparation.
If you can prepare you
know, practice questions,
similar environment setup,
practice time sessions,
giving yourself the opportunity to feel
like you're in a real
test taking environment
and that you have a
grasp on similar concepts
then it takes away a lot
of what I would often
think of with my students as
being the intimidating pieces.
And so you can practice the parts
that you can control I mean,
obviously there are pieces
you can never control.
But being able to
practice and get yourself
more comfortable with the pieces,
you can take away some of
that intimidation piece.
Sal, what do you think?
- No, I agree with all of that, obviously,
you can't understate the
value of preparation,
especially kind of preparation that match
with context and that, you know,
goes into something that's
taken me a long time to learn,
and I still remind myself all
the time is that, you know,
unless you can get focused on the outcome,
or you can get focused on the process.
And I think, you know, we
naturally our inner animals,
our egos, whatever, we tend
to get focused on the outcome,
I need to get an A on this
or think about how awesome
that would be or think about
how horrible it would be
if I fail this or assign this on tests.
And its just not on tests.
We do that with our careers.
We do that with pretty much
everything where we naturally
gravitate to the outcome
and kind of getting attached
to an outcome or having a
fear of a negative outcome.
And that's almost always
counterproductive.
It's much more valuable to
get focused on the process.
And then to say, yeah,
I'm gonna do my best
and this is kind of what you were saying
is like focus on the
process, get your practice.
And then the outcome is what it is.
And, you know, the more and ironically,
the more you get fixated on the outcome,
oftentimes the outcome won't be as good.
So that's, I think the
first thing and that's true.
You know, I'm preaching it.
I don't practice it in
everything in my life.
But when I do whenever I'm
getting stressed about something,
I'm getting anxious about something,
I'm like, look, it's just the process now.
Focus on what's in your locus of control,
do it the best you can, and
then the world will turn out
the way it does.
No point in stressing about it.
And then, you know, if I
were to continue to preach,
I would tell people don't you know,
don't underestimate meditation.
Even if you do 510 minutes
a day, sit quietly,
try to steal your mind, have fun with it.
Be curious, laugh about yourself,
when you get distracted.
You're gonna find that, you know,
it's a lot harder to take, you know,
a lot of things as seriously as sometimes
we do in a good way, in a good way.
So we're going back to some
of the teacher training
from Facebook.
Robin Schwartz asks, would
you recommend having this
and this is, you know what
we've been talking about around
the cons for educators, would
you recommend having this
be a part of new pre
service Teachers Training?
I would strongly recommend that.
And to be honest, the reason you know,
one of the key reasons that
we build conference educators
is because we heard and asked
from a lot of teachers saying,
I wanna be ready.
When my students come in
the door to my classroom,
I wanna know, as much as I
can before I get started.
And so we've been working
doing some teacher training
and support you know, in person,
but how could we reach more teachers
to support more students
around the country.
And so I would encourage
teachers who are pre service,
I would encourage teachers
who are even returning
to Khan Academy, we've really
gotten some great inputs
from teachers all over the
country who have shared tips
and tricks, along with diving
deeper into some of our tools
that are available on Khan Academy,
and even surfacing some
information on some new changes
we've made prior to back
to school this year.
So I would deeply encourage
pre service teachers
to engage with the course
and feel free to reach out
to us with with feedback and
things that would be helpful
for future iterations.
- And from Facebook, Sarah Louise asks,
Can you give some examples
of best practices,
I guess, you know, like,
what are some of the things
you see Meaghan, you
visit a lot of classrooms,
a lot of teachers, and
obviously you help teach
this calm for educators course.
You know, what were some
of the key headlines,
the cliff notes that
you think are you know,
when does Academy get used best?
- Sure, I'd say one thing
that is a misconception
sometimes is that we have all these tools,
and you should choose one, and that's it.
And I think what's really
amazing about Khan Academy
is that you can use the
course mastery system, sets
these long term goals for
students to work really on
the mastery of skills, but also
combine our Assignments tool
to narrow in on things
that are either curricular
align or adding in from another course,
or, you know, supporting
individual students on skills
or individual gaps that might be there.
So using both course mastery
and assigning a long term goal,
and supporting students
through assignment to hit
a short term goal so you
can hit all of your students
with the parts they need.
And we've got some advice
from teachers on how to do
that for a whole class or small groups,
how some advice on doing this
and perhaps a remote situation
that a lot of our teachers
are dealing with right now.
But really being able to
combine and integrate the tools
that are on Khan Academy
instead of just looking
at them all in isolation.
- Yep, yep.
So I have this question.
This is I guess which one for me
I'm not about control to ask Sal sir.
Thank you for,
- Very formal.
- I'm not used to that.
What is what is the one
thing you learned from all
your homeroom sessions
during this pandemic?
You know, I gotta say, I,
there's been so much I, you know,
when I started this, I didn't
expect that I would personally
enjoy it so much from a
learning point of view.
I thought it would be fun conversations.
But obviously, you know,
I think many of y'all saw
the conversation with Bill Gates.
That was a little bit of an eye opener.
We've been reading or hearing
a lot on the news back
then about COVID and how
it's all gonna play out.
But I think that was a
little bit of a wake up call
of how serious it was and how long lasting
this was going to be.
So that was a big thing.
I think Mellody Hobson.
Ray Dalio, several others, you know,
just talking about the
economic implications
and the powers of the Fed.
And, and you know, this
seeming continued disconnect
that we're seeing between the stock market
and what seems to be
happening on the ground,
and you know, people's everyday lives
and why that might be happening.
There's just been a ton
of people from Melbourne.
Hobson, Francis Ford Coppola
who talked about their life narrative,
and how they got to where they go.
And that's always a fun thing
because a lot of these people
that you read about or hear
about your whole life, no one
often asked them just like,
how did you end up here?
Like, what were you like as a kid?
And did you ever think you're gonna,
you know, win an Academy Award one day
or run a major company or whatever else?
I think the conversation with Bill Lewis
around race and what was happening,
I thought was very eye opening to me.
I thought I understood
many dimensions of it,
but I just added, you know,
just a more personal dimension.
You know, especially in terms
of including that, you know,
that whole incident that
happened in Central Park
with a dog walker and the birdwatcher
and kind of how, you know,
race was weaponized against
the birdwatcher.
I think, in the way Bill framed it,
I think was very eye opening to me.
I didn't fully appreciate
that dimension before.
I think we've done like 60
or 70 of these live streams.
So there have been a lot.
You know, I think the
conversation with Fareed Zakaria
went was very wide ranging lot there.
So, yeah, and a lot of the conscious
with our internal team members,
obviously, with Meaghan
now and then Martha,
you know, we learned about her journey
and I learned things about,
you know, team members
that I had known and I've worked with them
for many, many years.
So anyway, that's just a synopsis.
I'm really enjoying this,
because I feel like it's I'm
getting to learn alongside all
of y'all.
So let's see.
So there's a there from YouTube,
Susanna Garcia Domingo is
always asking great question.
Not too that we're judging
any of your other questions.
They're all great.
It's like, you know,
what's your favorite child
that we love them all?
Will there be a fall pacing
guide for each grade level?
I can make you on tape stop back
- I say sound.
Do you want us to share some
of your thoughts there first,
and then I'll add on.
- Yes.
Simple answer is yes.
Well, we're working on it.
Where we're at minimum, there's
going to be a pacing guide
that if let's say, a sixth grade student,
to be able to say, Okay,
what percent mastery
should you be at certain milestone points
over the course the year?
That's going to be there for sure.
And then we are figuring
out or thinking about
is there room for a kind of
deeper level of pacing guides?
You know, as you can imagine,
we're only about six weeks out.
But I'm, you know, myself
Meaghan, many other team members,
we're trying to figure out
what we could cobble together
to support as many as
many folks as possible
because you can imagine, most
traditional curricula are not
going to work well in
a hybrid environment.
I think people do need
help in and you know,
what Khan Academy resources
could even be used on
what particular days of assignments above
and beyond the mastery pacing,
but Meaghan, love your thoughts as well.
- Yeah, I think what you've touched on
is a lot of where many of
our heads are at right now
and how to best support
students and teachers
in this really unique environment.
And I think one thing
that's really helpful
that we're working on is right,
those new Get Ready for
grade level math courses
for third grade through pre-calculus.
We're working on how to
support teachers using
that with students and how close
some of that learning loss
that we know is even wider
this year.
And in conference caters and
some of this additional work
that sound is mentioned that
our colleague Vicki is leading.
We're working on how to, you
know provide recommendations on
when to transition from you know,
maybe using these Get Ready courses to on
grade level material because
we want to help close
that learning loss.
But we also want to make sure
that students are getting
the on grade level content
we need.
And so definitely something
our hearts and minds
are on right now is
providing the best resources
and recommendations we can.
- Yeah.
And there's a really a
comment from YouTube explorer
questioner says May the
fourth is teachers in the US
and September 5 in India,
just in case you'd like prepare to spoil
your favorite teacher with
gifts and appreciation.
One of our team members says
yes, it's on our calendar.
And hopefully every day is
teachers Appreciation Day.
But yeah, it would be good
to fund May the fourth
in the US and September 5 in India
and I'm sure and if your
country does not have
a teachers Appreciation
Day, hope it's every day
but maybe you want to
pick a day out as well.
Hopefully, yes.
spoil your teachers.
They deserve it.
- Absolutely.
- Let's see.
There's a so Alana goyle
from YouTube is asking,
how long would you recommend
us to study in a day?
So the sounds like a
little more of a you know,
Elena is working
independently on Khan Academy,
I would say is the summer,
well, if you're talking
about Khan Academy,
lets say math, I think
if you're able to put in
over the summer 30 to 45 minutes a day,
that's great, you're gonna
you know, use the Get Ready
for grade level courses that
Meaghan was talking about.
If you're already you know,
if you take the Get Ready for
grade level course challenge
and you get to 80% or 90% then just go
straight to grade level.
And if you do that 30 to
45 minutes a day working
at your own time and pace,
I am confident that you
are going to feel very good
the next school year and
you can just keep on going.
If you're talking about
studying across all
of your subjects, you know,
I care more about than you
are you always get to engage
in healthy things on top of your studying
studying can be healthy as well.
But you know, make sure you
have time to eat properly,
have time with your family, relax,
sleep, and you know what's
what's when studying
gets in the way of those things
that you have a problem and usually
that happens is you know,
this kind of binge studying
going on where you
procrastinate a long time
and then you know, for two
or three days you have to,
you know, the food, the
sleep, the time with family,
the relaxation goes
away and you just study
that less healthy.
Now we've all been there.
We've all done it.
But, you know, it's healthier
to pace yourself out.
Meaghan, any anything to add to that?
- That sounds, it sounds
like you nailed it there.
So I would I would say again,
right just what you're
saying make sure everything
in moderation, right.
- Yeah, no, that's absolutely
I like I will speak very honestly
as someone who has
trouble with moderation.
I mean, even the people are from Costco.
I'm going through them pretty intensely,
but yeah, everyone who knows me in my life
will tell you I have a moderation problem,
even when I can sometimes even be extreme
about trying to be moderate.
But anyway, that's a whole other issue.
This is a therapy session for me.
So let's see there's
so Ashish Joshi, please
develop something for kid
to gain knowledge on coding
and Khan Academy kids app.
Great idea.
It's not on the roadmap right now,
but it's a great idea.
But I recommend for the very young kids,
check out scratch,
there are close friends.
They have great stuff for younger kids,
and then our Khan Academy coding,
I think when students are
about third or fourth grade,
you can start to engage in it.
And it's kind of syntactic programming,
which is, you know, kind
of the type of programming
that programmers do.
So let's see.
McHale Govender, Hi, Sal and Meaghan,
how do you think the curriculum
will change in the future?
Meaghan?
And maybe I'll narrow it,
how do you think it's going to change
for this coming school year?
Because that's what you know,
I don't think a lot of
folks have had a chance
to even think about that.
- Yeah I think it's a
really tough question
that a lot of people are
grappling with everywhere
from, you know, the
state level to districts
to the individual classroom.
And I think the biggest
challenge this year is, you know,
teachers are used to dealing
with the summer slide
or learning loss in the US but
now we have this, you know,
extended time where students
haven't been you know,
in the classroom, per se.
I think the biggest challenge
for teachers is going to be,
how do I support students in
learning what they missed,
while also not letting them fall behind
from what they're supposed
to learn on grade level.
And I think some sort of
interleaving of, you know,
previous skills and
current skills is gonna be
even more prominent this year
than we've seen in years prior.
- Yeah, and I'll just
add to that, you know,
your traditional curricula
are based on this notion
of you have five class periods a week
that are 55 minutes long.
And that that kind of stays
consistently through the year
and the teacher can check your homework
and then give kind of a
well thought out lesson.
And obviously, in this COVID world,
whatever permutation it takes, you know,
the permutation seem to
be skewing more towards
what we saw in the spring because COVID
only picking back up.
You're not going to be able to do that.
You know, what the best
case that we've been seeing
is a teacher's leaning on Khan Academy,
both with the course mastery
and by making assignment
so that they can keep the track keep track
of what students are doing
at their own time and pace,
and then doing what's called
three synchronous sessions
over video conference a week,
maybe two of those sessions
are where teachers focus on
particular problem types
that they saw their students
have particular difficulty in,
and then maybe another
session where they just answer
any questions students have.
And so I think in this new framework,
which is very likely to
be at least the first half
of the school year,
but maybe this entire coming school year,
that's where you know, to
Susanna has original question.
Khan Academy has all of the content items
that we think could be very useful here.
Can we make it easy for
teachers to assign them
and maybe pace it out over
the course of the year,
they obviously can do the course mastery,
and then you know, how
and then what subset
of those assignments or
the items can be used
if teachers are able to get on
zoom or Google Hangout to do
those synchronous sessions.
My gut senses that's what
curriculum is going to look
like this coming year,
some teachers are going
to be able to go further
than that, but I actually think,
given how uncertain things are,
if we're able to just get
that level where kids are able
to get pretty far in their
mastery progress on Khan Academy,
they're able to
assignments and the teacher
is able to monitor and hold
them accountable, etc, etc.
I think, you know, given the
circumstances, very suboptimal,
but I think that would be a win,
given all of the uncertainty
that we're facing right now.
So it looks like we're all out of time,
Meaghan any parting words
for folks for relief?
- Just really excited
again to share that we have
this brand new opportunity
for educators all over the US
and that we are eager to
hear back from you and see,
you know, what do you think
and what you mean improve
to you know, make things
even better for you.
So looking forward to
hearing from all of you
- Yeah, well, thanks, Meaghan.
And thanks, you know, really
special thanks for Meaghan
and all the other people
in the CAD CAM team
who put together the con for
educators course obviously,
they've been doing amazing
work with educators.
The amazing ambassadors for years now.
And then this is just one more
thing that we're trying to do
especially in the COVID environment,
but to help support teachers,
and then obviously there's the Get Ready
for grade level courses.
We're going to be creating kind of pacing
guides learning plan,
but we'll try to get
as granular as possible
we're actually working
with a major kind of think
tank consulting company
on what are best practices
for back to school for district
so we're trying to do whatever we can.
And you know, we know this
is gonna be hard on parents,
on students and really hard on teachers.
But you know, that's what we're thinking
about day and night.
What can we do to support
y'all and what can we do
with especially over the next few weeks,
I also give a last shout out
I said this a couple of times
as a side project schoolhouse world
that I have some amazing
volunteers working on,
but that's the place where
you can get free live tutoring
and right now we have
several hundred tutors
who are waiting and
really incredible tutors.
I have to say I've been really
impressed with the folks
that have volunteered.
So if you if you know young people
or if you are a young person
who needs tutoring especially
in high school math right now,
you can get some high quality
free tutoring, which you know,
no strings attached.
So I'll also make that announcement.
So but thanks.
Thanks, Meaghan, for joining.
And you know, it's going to be
interesting next few months,
but I'm lucky to work with
Meaghan and everyone else
and hopefully we'll be able
to support all you teachers
out there as well as possible.
- Thank you Sal its a pleasure.
- Thanks, everyone.
Thank you for joining.
And we're now down to doing
this three days a week.
So I even the schedule is a little bit
but yes, we'll see you later this week.